[Musique]
bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver au sommaire de ça vous regarde
ce soir état d'urgence
stop ou encore l'opposition ne décolère
pas contre le projet de loi qui met
pourtant fin à l'état d'urgence
sanitaire le 10 juillet prochain alors
pourquoi tant de mécontentement alors
que les restrictions de libertés sont de
moins en moins nombreuses en témoigne la
manifestation à paris des soignants qui
a été autorisé eh bien parfois le diable
se niche dans les détails des textes de
loi on va le voir dans un instant avec
nos invités
on parlera aussi du rassemblement
national marine le pen est à l'offensive
elle vient de dénoncer un chaos
sécuritaire dans le pays depuis dijon où
elle s'est rendue après quatre jours
d'affrontements ultra violent entre
bandes armées crise sanitaire fermeture
des frontières patriotisme économique
défense des policiers l attaque tous
azimuts
une stratégie qui pour l'heure n'est pas
payante dans l'opinion
décryptage à suivre enfin le jour
d'après nouvel épisode de notre série
d'entretiens sur les conséquences du
corona des russes aujourd'hui la chine
pays d'où est parti le virus et qui
craint une contagion une deuxième vague
aujourd'hui l'ancien ambassadeur de
france à pékin jean maurice ripert a
répondu à nos questions voilà donc pour
le programme c'est parti à ce texte et
vert n'oubliez pas on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
regarder cette image des soignants des
soignants en nombre qui manifeste à
paris c'était aujourd'hui dans la
capitale entre le ministère de la santé
l'esplanade des invalides défilé au
démarrage dans le calme en début de
cortège et des personnels hospitaliers
vous le savez qui réclament des
revalorisations financière et puis
défilé vous le voyez qui a dégénéré en
fin de cortège à cause de casseurs qui
n'avait absolument rien à voir avec les
soignants si je vous montre ses images
marie-christine verdi joucla bonsoy soir
c'est parce qu'elles ont un lien avec le
sujet qui nous préoccupe ce soir l'état
d'urgence sanitaire officiellement les
rassemblements à l'heure où on se parle
de plus de 10 personnes ne sont pas
autorisées parce que l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
il est encore en vigueur jusqu'au 10
juillet prochain et pourtant je vois
c'est plus complexe
le gouvernement est bien les autorise on
a entendu le ministre de l'intérieur on
va en parler vous dialoguez je rappelle
que vous êtes député la république en
marche d'état vous dialoguez ce soir
avec pascal brindeau bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député udi du
loir et cher et vous vous aurais bien
aimé que c'est état d'urgence sanitaire
cessent immédiatement un peu plus tôt et
on verra pourquoi état d'urgence
sanitaire si j'ai bien compris il prend
fin le fin le 10 juillet prochain à
moins à moins que stéphane blakowski
tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bonsoir myriam en soir
à tous si j'ai bien compris ce soir ben
si j'ai bien compris myrian on insiste
un bras de fer entre le parlement et le
gouvernement
alors on va dire c'est quand même pas
une situation totalement inédite on
pourrait même dire c'est relativement
banal comme situation il suffit de faire
une recherche google avec les trois mots
clés bradfer parlement gouvernement vous
allez tomber sur des dizaines et des
dizaines d'artistes vous fait qui
rappelle pour se souvient que c'est pas
nouveau en 2018 a les bras de fer entre
parlement et gouvernement sur la réforme
institutionnelle au début de l'année
c'était bras de fer entre le parlement
et le gouvernement sur la réforme des
retraites
récemment c'était un bras de fer sur le
déconfinement sur le délai de vote
laisser au député bref entre
gouvernement et parlement c'est le bras
de fer permanent alors qu'elle est
l'objet du nouveau bras de fer et ben
vous l'avez dit c'est la levée de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire qui est prévue le 10
juillet et le problème c'est qu'au lieu
de supprimer purement et simplement
c'est sûr tu as d'urgence sanitaire à
cette date le projet de loi du
gouvernement qui sera votée demain
prévoit en réalité de donner des
pouvoirs d'exception au premier ministre
pendant encore quatre mois
supplémentaires peut-être le premier
ministre
si l'épidémie est derrière évidemment
uniquement si elle redémarre pourrait
interdire les déplacements pourraient
fermer certains endroits de
rassemblement ne pourrait pas interdire
les manifs mais ça serait quand même
encadrée avec des critères sanitaires
donc même pas mal de députés de
l'opposition qui sont assez sûr à tout
simplement puisque il ya une commission
mixte paritaire c'est-à-dire sénateurs
et députés qui s'étaient mis d'accord
sur la date 10 juillet pas plus tard
pour l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
finalement sous couvert de levée de
l'état d'urgence bah on a eu
l'impression qu'il est maintenu c'est ce
que va vous dire pascal brindeau mais il
avait déjà hier commission donc on est
toutes un maintien en réalité deux
dispositions exceptionnelles
attentatoires de libertés collectives et
individuelles permettant
à l'exécutif de faire fi des droits du
parlement sur un certain nombre de
sujets dont le jour ce qui inquiète que
les députés bon j'imagine que c'est pas
nécessairement l'idée que les noirs sud
il se transforme d'un coup d'un seul
coup en dictateur cc - ça l'objet en
fait ce qui les exaspère surtout c'est
que le gouvernement us
très vite une solution il pourra prendre
des décisions sans tenir compte de
l'avis du parlement puisque ce que
prévoit le projet de loi qui est proposé
demain c'est que le gouvernement décide
on informe le parlement mais on se
remplissent de son avis donc voilà un
nouveau bras de fer entre le
gouvernement et parlement a lancé donc
d'un côté le gouvernement
le lg rose it sans avoir à justifier en
permanence devant l'opposition de
l'autre le parlement veut faire son
boulot c'est à dire pouvoir amender
pouvoir contrôler l'action du
gouvernement dans un souci donc pas
d'efficacité de mai de démocratie et
donc je vous dirais bien qu'il ya du
suspense mais qui va emporter ce nouveau
bras de fer
sauf que dans la vème république il ya
moyennement de suspense entre eux dans
les querelles entre gouvernement et le
parlement s'est souvent que dans ce film
dont on connaît toujours la fin merci
beaucoup stéphane vous restez avec nous
pour ce débat on dirait que pascal
brindeau c'est la fin de l'état
d'urgence donc le 10 juillet mais c'est
la faim en trompe l'oeil c'est ça à
écouter contrairement à ce qui est le
titre du projet de loi qui nous est
présenté
celui ci n'a pas vocation à mettre fin à
l'état d'urgence mais à prolonger des
mesures dites exceptionnelles prises
dans le cadre d'un état d'urgence je
rappelle que l'état d'urgence créé par
la loi de 60 à 2955 ça correspond à une
situation du pays très particulière
deuxième état d'urgence sont les
attentes à 15 en 2015 est le troisième
état d'urgence l'état d'urgence
sanitaire a été créée effectivement dans
le cadre du cosy de l est liberticide
cette loi les mots sont forts liberté
c'est franchement oui parce que le
conseil d'état d'ailleurs dans sa
décision de samedi dernier mentionne que
même dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire la liberté de manifester ne
peut pas être totalement interdite dans
notre pays
c'est une question d' équilibre entre
les libertés individuelles les libertés
collectives qui sont protégés par notre
constitution qui fondent notre état de
droit
ce qui fonde aussi quelque part la
république dont on aujourd'hui qu'elle
est abîmée et on voit des images depuis
quelques jours qui montrent que cette
république elle est sympa avec par en
danger j'imagine qu'on en parlera et ça
nous ramène à ce sujet le gouvernement
les pouvoirs publics l'état pour qu'il
soit entendu pour qu'il soit crédible il
faut que ces décisions soient équilibrés
elles ne le sont pas dans son interview
aux craintes mais vous avez vu qu'en
chine on crée un regard de contagion
notamment à pékin il ya 100 cadres
évidemment notre régime n'a rien à voir
avec celui de pékin mais on se dit tout
de même si jamais il y avait cette
deuxième vague si jamais ce virus
circulait à nouveau on voit bien que
c'est compliqué l'incertitude demeure sa
pas forcément saisonniers puisqu'il fait
chaud là bas
est ce qu'il ne faut pas des outils tout
de même coûté lorsque la crise s'est
déclenchée
le président de la république pour les
ministres ont décidé de la fermeture des
établissements recevant du public avant
le vote de cette loi d'urgence
je rappelle qu'elle date du 20 mars et
que à cette date là les restaurants
étaient déjà fermés et ses emails alors
regardez les ces images là est ce qu
elles vous font pas peur franchement
imaginer des manifestations évidemment
la distance d un d un maître n'est pas
possible si le virus arrive liberté de
manifester oui mais s'il revient alors
là on est dans les images que je vois en
ce moment dans quelque chose d'autre que
la liberté de manifester ça et ça me
désole parce qu'en plus on est sur une
thématique des soignants qui veulent se
faire entendre pour améliorer leurs
conditions de travail et des bandes de
casseurs qui viennent à dessein pour
brouiller le message de ces
manifestations et qui poursuivent des
objectifs politiques très clair c'est à
dire la remise en cours condamné les
violences vie que la remise en cause des
principes de l'ordre républicain et ça
n'est pas acceptable dans un état de
droit et dans le pays qui est le nôtre
mais scellier scellier aussi est
justement ces manifestations si elles
ont lieu à répétition on sent bien que
le pays
voilà bouillonne qui a un peu un effet
cocotte minute quel conseil d'état marie
christine bien dit joucla qui vient de
dire très clairement on ne peut plus
leur interdire les manifestations pour
des raisons sanitaires et en même temps
continuer d'interdire les manifestations
culturelles alors et c'est là où est la
logique et juste les concerts anglais
l'air où est la logique
simplement là c'est le juge des référés
du conseil d'état qui a décidé de
justement parce que ben voilà la liberté
de manifester trop importante en france
à condition que les distingue ce soit
appliqué qui le port de masque on voit
ce que ça peut donner cet après midi à
côté de cela le gouvernement est en
responsabilité le virus je crois que
l'oubli continue à circuler même si les
mots inactifs et qu'il est pour
l'instant l'attend il ya quand même des
dernières études de
mais 2,5 de scientifiques qui parle
d'une possibilité à l'automne d'une
deuxième vague plus plus cruel donc à
tonnerre responsabilité mais tout a
tourné en faveur des conseils à
christophe castaner 1 qu'il le dit
clairement je crois que l'émotion
mondial et ça c'était après oui il a man
parce que c'était pas la lande états
unis mais l'a dit ça il pourrait leur
dire avec la question des soignants
l'émotion mondiale et sur ce sujet
regret va pas au fond les règles
juridiques qui s'applique mais vous
comprenez que pelé machine on regarde at
war avec sa pente pleinement
incompréhensible avis c'est pour ça que
moi je ne suis pas d'accord parce qu'on
n'est pas sur le même registre est
aujourd'hui si vous voulez moi ce que je
considère c'est qu'on n'est par rapport
aux soignants et je comprends très bien
leurs envies leurs besoins leurs
réclamations qu'on connaît depuis
longtemps
il a indiqué que cette manifestation des
soignants elle a été déposée en
préfecture et elle était autorisée qu'on
la première manifestation l'a autorisée
et voilà qu'on l'a autorisé avec
l'écossé qu'on pouvait donner enfin
qu'il fallait préconisé mais je on est
en pleine figure de la santé oms
reviennent toujours à ce qu'il y avait
avant la crise et malheureusement la
crise n'a rien changé de ce côté là moi
j'ai fait le ségur de la santé dans ma
circonscription dans mon département
avec mon collègue et j'ai tout fait
remonter au ministre la santé tous les
collègues ont fait la même chose le
ministre est en train de faire à son
niveau exactement les mêmes
présentations ils ont lancé une
concertation sur internet comme élu
voleur d'un fessionnels 50000 que la
reddition et figure le jeu ne restait
pas assez vous leur dites c'est jeudi à
chose de moi je ne comprends les talus
je ne comprends plus ce pays où on ne
fait plus confiance finalement quand on
fait des concertations quand on se met
autour de la table pour discuter pour
négocier et où on a le sentiment qu'il
faut aller dans la rue pour faire un
bras de fer pour obliger à moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on jouait john cela
c'est la question de l'autorité de
l'état qui est posée oui mais après à 7
alors je mets de côté les violences qui
a eu cet après-midi parce que c'est pas
les soignants c'est effectivement voilà
toujours pareil c'est ces casseurs qui
viennent semer le trouble et qui
finalement interdisent en france de
pouvoir manifester dans le calme mais on
est quand même encore dans cet état
d'urgence moi je suis contente que le
gouvernement nous propose
finalement une sortie progressive de cet
état d'urgence alors juste ce domaine on
doit arriver à de nouveau avoir un
problème au niveau sanitaire mais moi je
suis contente que le gouvernement puisse
prendre des mesures pour nous protéger
les sortie progressive mais pendant
quatre mois le premier ministre
s'il réserve jusqu'à fin octobre se
réserve du droit mais des droits mais on
va regarder la liste c'est pas rien
c'est l'instruction elle porte sur les
déplacements de personnes les
rassemblements sur la voie publique dont
on voit qu'avec les manifestations
aujourd'hui on est plus dans la logique
les transports oui et les établissements
recevant du public on peut même se dire
que l'essai des écoles mais c'est en
fait il pour confiner pays avec sa wii
l'eau non il ne peut par confiner le
pays totalement ça c'est pas prévu dans
la loi mais par contre il peut
effectivement appliqué une ou plusieurs
des mesures mais attendez je crois que
l'on n'oublie vraiment qu'on sort d'une
crise sanitaire où on a eu combien de
morts combien de personnes on perdrait
en tenir leurs proches
vous comprenez donc je crois que moi ce
que je veux c'est un état qui me protège
et on sait la lourdeur quand même aussi
malgré tout du parlement dans le choix
des décisions et c est ce que c'est
vraiment gênant d'autoriser le
gouvernement
aujourd'hui oui mais est-ce que c'est
vraiment gênant aujourd'hui d'autoriser
le gouvernement de prendre des
dispositions qui sont clairement écrites
qui sont censés nous protéger si
effectivement le virus revient de plus à
plat actifs vous allez vous avez répond
pas de quel grade hommes et par mes deux
meilleurs this in health à d'habitude
c'est vos collègues de socialistes qui
parlent de liberticide mais quand même
on n'est pas dans une divertissements
écoutez c'est peut-être assez symbolique
du coup de savoir que
sur les bancs de gauche sur les bandes
de droite sur les bancs du centre il y a
des gens qui sont attachés à défendre
les libertés individuelles et libertés
mais ça n'est pas madame au prix de la
santé encore une fois le pays a été
confiné avant même
que la loi d'urgence du 20 mars était
prise et
j'ai signifié une sortie progressive de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
d'un point de vue juridique ça n'existe
pas je vois les conditions constitutifs
de l'état d'urgence existent encore et
dans ce cas l'état d'urgence n'est pas
levée soit elle n'existe plus et il est
levé
aujourd'hui le président de la
république vient devant les français
d'hier le virus est sous contrôle
il n'a pas dit qu'il avait disparu et
personne n'a entendu dans sa bouche qui
les disent pas maîtrisé il a dit aussi
qu évidemment il fallait continuer
d'observer des gestes barrières les
précautions nécessaires etc
il a dit aussi que la vie devait
reprendre son cours normal la vie
économique
la vie sociale la vie démocratique
l'organiser le président de la
république et la loi ce que j'avais
oublié sa semaine et le matin qui dit la
vie normale doit reprendre et ça veut
dire que ça veut dire que donc les
libertés qui sont les nôtres
encadrés par la loi protégé par les
construire la constitution doivent et
bien être rétablie comme comme elle
comme elle le sait faire avec un état
d'urgence
stéphane blakowski qui vous écoutent
voudrais vous interrogez moi je
m'étonnais un petit peu malgré tout que
le gouvernement n'est ce pas le soin aux
élus de la nation de s'exprimer gens que
vous disiez point de vue de la majorité
ben ça me rassure que le gouvernement
puisse décider ça devrait aussi à coeur
quand une décision est prise les députés
soit exposé de loi on va s'exprimer au
moment de voter le texte de loi est
peut-être comme à l'amendé peut-être
comme à le bouger la majorité pour vous
dispenser justement pour exclure ensuite
comment on a vendu sa maison pour
poursuivre la question n'était pas
d'accord ce qui tout à l'heure monsieur
brun tôt nous explique que le
confinement il a eu lieu avant même le
vote de l'état d'urgence sanitaire a le
confinement de tout le pays dans leurs
murs des échos finalement c'est la belge
et une hausse chez la fermeture juste
des restaurants et les écoles qui ont
fermé avant que la loi ne soit votée ça
veut dire très concrètement aujourd'hui
plutôt à des crises ont suffi pour
confiner tout ou partie du territoire
vous ne servez à rien finalement à quoi
sert l'état d'urgence sanitaire si le
gouvernement peut confiner par un simple
des cloches je ne suis là disons que je
vous pose ce combat là
dans ce projet de loi puisse se régler
par décret et s'il faut pas justement
que ce soit inscrit au niveau législatif
je suis ne suis pas du tout certaine que
tout soit parce qu'elles rendent écrit
parce que si effectivement il suffit
d'un décret pour tous je vous rejoins à
quoi ça sert effectivement de sa veste
et restrictions mais c'est là que ya
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de questions
débat n'est pas là tu le prennes voie
réglementaire et le pouvoir législatif
prix mais le débat il est dans le fait
d'inscrire dans le droit commun des
mesures exceptionnelles qui sont des
mesures de restriction des libertés ou
ne peut pas contester le fait que ceux
des mesures de restriction des libertés
l'article 2 l'article 2 c'est aussi la
prolongation du délai d'épreuve de ses
parts de non non l'article 2 du projet
de loi c sur le délai de conservation
des données personnelles issues de la
mise en place non pas du soin de stopper
la mise en place du fichier médical issu
de l'article 6 de la précédente loi de
liberté c'est pour quatre mois il ya la
question des données médicales
mais là c'est quatre mois jusqu'à fin
octobre vous craignez vous est en
octobre
s'il ya des reprendre alors on nous dit
prolongation de l'état d'urgence jusque
janvier 2021
4 - sur encore il fait on finit par
inscrire parce que ça s'est déjà fait
comme cela j'en suis au terrorisme on a
inscrit dans le dur de la loire jean les
assignations à résidence
oui mais l'horizon mais qui mais qui
pour certaines dans le trail peuvent
être démesuré en temps en temps normal
il faut et enfin le le la notion de
sécurité et c'est quelqu'un mais les
centraux droite
la notion de sécurité ne peut pas
justifier une atteinte permanente
définitive à des libertés nous sommes
dans le pays des libertés
nous sommes dans le pays de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme ça
veut dire quelque chose pour tente avec
le gouvernement de vouloir car les
usages des données
qu'il nous explique pouvoir maintenir
les études sur locaux vides je suis
assis à chaque fois que chaque décision
du gouvernement comme une volonté
presque quasi complotistes ici on nous
écoute d'utiliser ces données pour je ne
sais quoi d'ailleurs
on ne peut pas imaginer qu'ils veulent
juste poursuivre des études sur le virus
apparaît complètement insensé non je ne
donne pas de péché par une quelconque
volonté deux jeux je les accuse de
pêcher par facilité facilité qui
consiste effectivement à se dire on
prend un paquet maximum de mesures
possibles je ne dis pas qu'elles seront
mises en oeuvre
il y aura ce seront sans doute pas si le
texte devait 7e pierce a adopté en
l'état oui mais alors on est on légifère
pas dans ce pays mais case ou enfin ce
que je peux répondre oui elle moi je
vous accuse de faire opposition pour
faire opposition
et quand même même dans une situation
que vous avez vos amis du modem de
commandes et de l'omh ans qu'il commence
à sérieusement agacer par le principe je
ne vous ai pas allez-y
mais qui à l'âge de deux mois et demie
de confinement en sorte de mettre en
place des mesures pour essayer de sauver
nos entreprises
on est en train de regarder un plan de
relance pour vraiment sauver les
entreprises parce que rien n'est gagné
à un moment donné où on devrait tous
être unis non mais sincèrement en quoi
c'est gênant
demain de voter ce texte qui permet au
gouvernement de pouvoir prendre des
décisions pour protéger les français
c'est là où je n'arrive pas à comprendre
et c'est là où je vous dis mais moi je
vous accuse de dos vous opposez pour
vous au point d'un passé noir bonnes
questions et faire qu'on réduise a
perdus à minima ma liberté
si ça permet de sauver des vies et c'est
pour ça que moi j'ai l'application store
provident par exemple alors restreindre
les libertés pour sauver des vies c'est
la grande question que nos voisins
européens se sont aussi posées est-ce
que pour autant ils sont passés par des
votes d'état d'urgence bonsoir richard
wehrli vous êtes là le correspondant
parisien du quotidien suisse le temps
est notre chroniqueur fidèles du mardi
détenir un peu comment les autres pays
l'union qui ont dû se poser les mêmes
questions et ont répondu est-ce qu'ils
ont recouru à des lois d'exception comme
l'état d'urgence et bien tout à fait y
en fait en europe deux écoles il y à
l'école de l'état d'urgence à la
française avec en plus la surveillance
policière les attestations
le meilleur exemple il remonte au 31
janvier on l'a oublié vous savez on a
beaucoup pas accusé l'italie de laxisme
et bien en fait c'est dès le 31 janvier
que les italiens aux activés l'état
d'urgence après ça a mis du temps pour
que les décrets en prenant entre en
oeuvre il a fallu attendre le 4 mars
pour que cet état d'urgence sanitaire
soit proclamée en italie alors quels
sont les autres pays qui sur le mode
français ont choisi l'état d'urgence je
dirais le kit complet et bien il y à
l'espagne l'espagne c'est le 14 mars il
y a surtout des pays ancien communiste
il y à la lettonie et l'estonie
il y à la roumanie il y a bien sûr la
hongrie vous savez que la victor hörmann
s'est même fait attribuer des pouvoirs
d'exception qui lui permettait de
légiférer quasiment sur tous les
domaines par décret il y a une autre
école en europe et c'est très
intéressant cet autre l'école elle est
quand même constitué de la majorité de
nos voisins alors on peut citer la
belgique on peut citer la suisse
l'allemagne l'autriche
ces pays n'ont pas voulu un état
d'urgence généralisée ils ont délégué au
pouvoir exécutif un certain nombre de
prérogatives supplémentaires ça s'est
fait en gros entre le 15 et le 25 mars
mais il n'y a pas eu de chèque en blanc
signé au pouvoir exécutif et ça c'est
très important parce qu'on en voit
aujourd'hui les conséquences et on le
retrouve dans le débat qu'on vient
d'entendre parce que dans les pays qui
ont eu un état d'urgence le plus complet
à la française qu'est ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui il y à des commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires ce qui témoigne
quand même d'une vraie frustration sur
la manière dont la crise a été gérée
céderait en italie c'est vrai en espagne
dans les autres pays
qu'est-ce qu'il ya eu des task force
dans lesquels siéger des élus pendant
toute la crise du cobp hymne au fond ces
pays qui n'ont pas recouru à l'état
d'urgence à la française on peut être
mieux réussi a fait rimer l'unité avec
l'efficacité
merci beaucoup rezar pour votre
éclairage ça fait réfléchir tu m'aimes
madame inverse des chocolats oui ça fait
réfléchir mais pour autant je suis
persuadé
en france on aurait calmé u10 enquête
parlementaire ah oui oui vraiment parce
que l' enquête parlementaire
nous on la crème pas parce que je crois
qu'on doit tous savoir exactement ce qui
s'est passé pour pouvoir mettre en avant
les forces mettre en avant les
faiblesses en parler dans un verger ça
c'est clair
saisissez pays vous allez dans l'édition
c'est la cinquième république
ouais c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est et on a du mal à 1 malgré
tout se mettre tous autour d'une table
et de se dire on est d'accord pour
avancer vers un seul objectif
moi je me suis engagé en politique et un
marche pour ça parce que l'idée c'était
de rassembler large avec tous ceux qui
avaient la même volonté main se rend
compte malgré tout que la politique
politicienne elle existe toujours moi je
fais le constat tous les jours et quand
je vois que les socialistes hier excusez
moi n'ont pas voté la cinquième manche
et que vous vous êtes un mappage de
l'année pendant de la dépendance et que
vous vous êtes abstenu
les bras m'en tombent alors que les deux
mandats ou sa et ses bras de ramé à
correa derrière cette question c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait à la crise l'union
nationale semble impossible et une
minute doré dommage si vous le permettez
d'abord s'opposer pour s'opposer je
rappelle que les députés udf ont voté
l'état d'urgence le premier la première
fois sur l'état d'urgence et la deuxième
en majorité mais nous avions déjà des
inquiétudes parce que nous dénoncions
déjà la tendance naturelle des
gouvernements pas celui ci tous à
inscrire dans le droit commun des
mesures exceptionnelles mais la
confiance n'exclut pas le contrôle la
confiance d'une part elle n'exclut pas
le contrôle et la confiance elle se
construit quand vous dites on appelle à
l'unité et personne ne répond c'est
peut-être que et cette confiance ça
n'existe pas chez les français non plus
c'est parce que des erreurs ont été
commises des erreurs de communication
mais aussi des erreurs tout simplement
de gestion de la stratégie et sa selle
dans la crise et la demande aujourd'hui
se couchait transit appelait unité
nationale et je n'ai juste un mythe
justement on va en parler de ses erreurs
commises
est ce nécessaire diagnostic certains
parlent déjà même des preuves de vérité
la commission d' enquête parlementaire a
commencé ses travaux avec l'audition de
jérôme salomon et c'est thomas
thomas des prêts qui va nous raconter
dans le détail l'audition du directeur
général de la santé oui exactement
myriam c'est aujourd'hui que débutent
les auditions de la commission d'
enquête sur le coran un virus avec
l'audition de jérôme salomon le
directeur général de la santé je vous
raconte tout ça alors cette mission
d'information va se doter pour 6 mois
donc des pouvoirs d'une commission
denquête avec l'objectif d'investiguer
sur des points très précis la question
des tests la gestion de l'épidémie dans
les ehpad les frontières la question des
grands rassemblements sportifs mais
surtout la gestion en termes de masques
40 députés la composent avec un seul
objectif faire toute la lumière sur
l'épidémie pourra pas se satisfaire d'un
exercice d'autosatisfaction où tout va
bien dans le meilleur des mondes à
l'image du discours présidentiel de
dimanche soir si on veut éviter que
cette crise ne recommence avec les mêmes
difficultés pour la france il faut faire
la transparence la vérité et avoir tous
les éléments de précision a un devoir
d'explication de transparence pour
comprendre ce qui a dysfonctionné d'y
apporter les remèdes et d'établir si des
responsabilités politiques quand on
regarde ce qui s'est passé en france
comparé à ce qui s'est passé ailleurs en
europe qu'on peut être collectivement
fier de la gestion de la crise par le
gouvernement mais ça n'exonère pas le la
nécessité d'aller regarder ce qui a
moins bien fonctionné pour l'améliorer
pour le futur il faut vraiment que cette
crise est bien nous en tirions
réellement tous les enseignements pour
nos démocraties sortent davantage
renforcée et surtout pour en éviter
d'autres peut-être également d'autres
ampleur bonsoir thomas thomas des prêts
à cette commission dans quelle est donc
toujours en cours avec la première
audition de jérôme salle au monde et
nous dites nous tout et bien voilà
exactement jérôme salomon le directeur
général de la santé c'est le premier que
les députés ont voulu interroger
vous savez jérôme seulement on était
habitué à le voir tous les soirs à la
télévision égrainé le nombre de victimes
du coït 19 et là il a juré aujourd'hui
de dire rien que la vérité toute la
vérité notamment sur la question des
masques où il est beaucoup interrogé par
les députés notamment par le président
du groupe l'est républicain damien abad
pourquoi avons nous manqué de masques au
début écoutez monsieur direction
générale le 4 mars dernier
vous déclariez sur bfm les masques n'ont
aucun intérêt pour le grand public
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous regrettez vos
propos comme disait voltaire il a été
repris souvent depuis avant de savoir
on ne sait pas nous avons toujours suivi
les recommandations internationales
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
beaucoup hésité et vous avez noté
qu'elle recommande désormais le port du
masque dans certaines circonstances
depuis le 5 juin et lorsque le grand
public a voulu des masques nous avons
produit des masques vous le savez
adapter
grâce aux compétences de nos industriels
et de nos artisans en france alors
depuis à 17h15 le début de cette
audition les députés ont beaucoup
interrogé jérôme salomon qui n'a pas
toujours répondu avec précision
l'occasion d'une petite mise au point de
brigitte bourguignon la présidente de
cette commission d' enquête sur la
question du stock des masques écouter
permet juste de rappeler un peu le
contexte de cette commission denquête
qui demande évidemment des réponses
précises à des questions précises
voilà myriam à l'heure où on se parle
l'audition de jérôme salomon est
toujours en cours vous pouvez d'ailleurs
la suivre dès la fin de sévères sur les
réseaux sociaux d'elle cp et puis demain
les députés écouteront et 10 youn rond
la présidente de santé publique france
et son prédécesseur qui seront
interrogés donc mais ça on aura
l'occasion de reparler dans ma journée à
l'assemblée
merci beaucoup thomas pascal brindeau
fait commission denquête elle doit faire
la lumière vous pensez qu'elle qu'elle
peut faire un diagnostic véritablement
comment dire utile au pays où elle est
déjà politiques toutes les commissions
d'enquêté sont politique au sens où est
bien le parlement est là pour contrôler
l'action du gouvernement
c'est une des deux fonctions
essentielles des députés de la nation
donc oui elle est là pour effectivement
faire la lumière sur ce qu'a été la
gestion de la crise sanitaire dans ce
qu'elle a réussi
et puis dans les échecs qui ont été les
nôtres en france elle récupère les clés
notamment dans la gestion des masques
parce que on le voit on les aime et
c'est maintenant dire qu'on ne savait
pas peut-être mais enfin nous avons des
exemples internationaux deux pays qui
ont connu la crise sanitaire ou qui ont
des habitudes de gestion des crises
sanitaires notamment des coronavirus par
le port du masque en matière de
prévention et qui ont quand même des
effets donc on ne pouvait pas dire qu'on
ne savait pas si parce qu'il ya 80 plein
ça voulait pas à la hauteur de ce rendez
vous avec les français parce qu'ils vont
regarder les auditions vous risquez de
creuser encore plus mature et la
défiance on risque rien au sens où tout
ce qu'on a fait on l'a fait de bonne foi
je suis désolé mais moi ça commence à
m'agacer de penser qu'on a manipulé
qu'on a triché qu'on a menti
non non et non les pourparlers vernement
quand vous parlez du coronavirus vous
parlez des coronavirus vous n'avez aucun
coronavirus qui a fait les dégâts que
celui là a fait partout dans le monde en
même temps vous n'avez aucun coronavirus
qui a commencé par attaquer la chine là
où on avait tous les outils de
production et pourquoi on avait tous les
outils de production de masques et de
matériel et de médicaments là bas c'est
là où commence la mission délicate et
c'est là où il faut se poser la question
mais sincèrement moi je suis d'accord de
toute façon pour que cette mission une
enquête puisse se faire la lumière sur
ce qui a fonctionné et ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné pour le futur et pour demain
mais vous pouvez pas m'empêcher de
croire que pour certains ça va au delà
de cela et que c'est bien politique au
sens où pensez qu'il peut mais ne
serait-ce le président parce que tous
mais pas que lui parce que tout ce qui
peut nuire au gouvernement il y en a
quand même qui en ont fait un parti
personnel de faire en sorte que tout ce
qui peut nuire au gouvernement soit mise
en avant
donc là il ya une très belle tribune
mais dans la mesure où on n'a rien à
cacher et dans la mesure où on assumera
les erreurs
il y aura eu si erreur il y a eu parce
que pour l'instant moi ce que je vois au
secteur nevers dijon qui n'a pas dit sa
mère que même le gouvernement et le
président les reconnaître ces rapts et
même justement si erreur il ya parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a tendance à condamner
quand même avant d'avoir le résultat
mais ce que je vois moi c'est qu'à
chaque fois on a pu faire face faire
face aux responsabilités ont fait deux
fois prendre des décisions qui n'étaient
pas faciles à prendre
très bien merci à vous merci gêné mende
est revenu sur le plateau d'el cp les
français suivront d'ailleurs sur lcp ces
auditions de la commission d' enquête
sur la crise sanitaire ou à parler à
présent de la stratégie du rassemblement
national marine le pen à l'offensive
était à dijon cet après midi après des
scènes surréalistes d'affrontements
entre bandes armées
pendant quatre jours et vous allez le
voir elle tape fort étape très fort vous
allez l'entendre cela fait des semaines
d'ailleurs qu'elle occupe le terrain
celui de la première opposante à
emmanuel macron dans la crise sanitaire
celui de la première supportrice aussi
des forces de l'ordre à leur nation
insécurité souveraineté les thèmes de
l'actualité devrait la porter est ce le
cas éléments de réponse avec radhika on
ne sait plus si l'on est au far west ou
à bagdad dans orange mécanique ou dans
mad max je n'ai pas à m'excuser pour la
mort d'un délinquant adama traoré depuis
des semaines le rassemblement national
est sur tous les fronts
l'actualité a mis marine le pen et ses
lieutenants sur le devant de la scène
dernier épisode en date ici à dijon
marine le pen est la première figure de
l'opposition à se déplacer sur le
terrain depuis vendredi soir
dijon est le théâtre de violents
affrontements entre la communauté
tchétchène et les habitants du quartier
populaire des grésillés la france qui
croyait tranquillement revenir à la vie
après une période d'enfermement imposée
s'est réveillé dans les vociférations de
haine indigéniste cette haine raciale
sous couvert d'antiracisme et cette
haine communautariste antilles
françaises
le tout s'accompagnant de violences
urbaines une situation qui illustre la
thèse défendue déjà la semaine dernière
à propos de la manifestation interdite
mais finalement autorisée sur les
violences policières et je pense que ce
que nous avons vécu depuis trois jours
et la révélation de l'abandon par le
gouvernement du respect de l'état de
droit
dijon manifestations pro traoré flics en
colère autant de sujets qui devraient
ouvrir un boulevard à marine le pen
pourtant son parti semble peiner à en
tirer profit
question de temps pour ce député est en
réalité ce qui se passe aujourd'hui est
validée valide plutôt le discours du
rassemblement national et l'analyse que
nous avons fait depuis longtemps
malheureusement je devrais dire oui je
crois que le temps n'est pas arrivé à la
lecture politique de ces événements
d'ailleurs ces événements ne sont pas
finis aujourd'hui la crise économique
qui commence la crise de société la
crise politique la crise de l'état de
droit
mobilisent l'attention des français et
ce n'est pas aujourd'hui que les
français distribue les bons et les
mauvais points en attendant le parti
croule sous les dettes même s'il a
échappé au pire
le rassemblement national vient d'être
condamné à verser près de 20000 euros
d'amendé pour recel d'abus de biens
sociaux dans le financement des
élections législatives de 2012
une petite victoire pour le parti l'état
lui réclamer 11,6 millions d'euros
bonsoir jean yves camus bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes le directeur
de l'observatoire des radicalités
politique à la fondation jean jaurès et
chercheur à l'ires us est bienvenu avoue
frédéric dabi ravis de vous accueillir
sur ce plateau vous êtes le directeur
général adjoint de l'institut ifop ainsi
de comprendre au fond un paradoxe des
partis extrémistes et du rassemblement
national tout la porte marine le pen a
priori quand on regarde les thèmes de
cette crise sanitaire
et là encore les violences à dijon et
pourtant et pourtant elle ne semble pas
traduire au fond cela dans l'opinion
fonde avec david comment l'expliquer
déjà ces périodes de crise intense
l'opinion regarde plus les prises de
parole les actions du pouvoir exécutif
que des partis d'opposition je
nuancerais quand vous dites tout la
porte il ya une crise sanitaire très
forte on a vu mais ça fait plusieurs
semaines qu'on enregistre une inquiétude
crise économique est très clairement
quand on interroge les français sur des
enjeux qui vont plus compté au cours des
mois prochains lauriad
il ya eu bien sûr cette poussée digèrent
très spectaculaire à dijon on reste sur
des thématiques économiques et sociales
le chômage redeviennent des premières
préoccupations des français sur lequel
le rassemblement national est moins à
l'aise que sur les thématiques
insécurité immigration et puis marine le
pen elle a une posture de cassandre
c'est à dire je vous l'avais dit je vous
l'avais dit qu' il fallait fermer la
frontière avec la chine je vous l'avais
dit qu'il fallait qu'on finit plus vite
qu'il fallait des confiné plus vite etc
et souvent cette posture que les
français apprécient ce que son électorat
apprécié quand on interroge des
électeurs qui ont voté au moins une fois
pour le rassemblement national c'était
une enquête il faut fiducial pour le jdd
d'il ya 2 3 ans c'était le premier
constat le premier levier de de soutien
c'était le fn et marine le pen dresse
des constats juste sur l'état de la
société
et là on entend on entend monsieur chenu
90 à marine le pen
ça leur donne raison mais sur la
question des solutions sur la question
du comment faire là le rassemblement
national reste cantonné pour beaucoup de
français à sa posture tribunicienne
dernier plan quand on interroge les
français sur à ce que chacun toute une
série de personnalités ferait mieux -
bien qu'elle macron dans le cadre de la
crise
alors justement c'est elle qui a le
meilleur score de furets mieux mais
c'est aussi elle qui a le meilleur le
moins bon score c'est à dire elle ferait
moins bien
on voit là la limite de cette posture on
a trouvé un sondage de les femmes je
crois du mois de mai justement c'est la
question qui était posée si vous étiez à
la place d'emmanuel macron on posait la
question aux français
pensez vous pensez vous que cette
personne ferait mieux alors val commenté
avec 20% pour pour marine le pen devant
jean-luc mélenchon françois baroin
yannick jadot et nicolas sarkozy
absolument comme on n'est pas sûr qu'il
soit candidat
on n'a pas mis on l'a pas retenu 20 % on
se dit quoi c'est son socle elle
n'arrive pas à élargir et au delà alors
elle va au delà de ce socle de 20% on
l'a fait la présidentielle ont ainsi
dans toute une série d'élections mais
c'est vrai que dans les moments de crise
il ya d'abord un réflexe légitimiste une
sorte de deux réflexes du drapeau de
l'opinion publique qui apportait
énormément edouard philippe
mais aussi également emmanuel macron il
a une cote de popularité aujourd'hui
supérieure à celle qu'il avait avant la
crise du coc vide
et sur le moins bien il ya toute une
série de français et puis des des
catégories qui sont des catégories à
conquérir pour le rassemblement national
les personnes âgées des diplômes et les
cadres supérieurs qui ne voudrait
surtout pas une marine le pen au pouvoir
en temps de crise c'est la limite de
cette posture tribunicienne et de
cassandre
ça vous surprend je rêve camus au fond
que marine le pen ne profite pas de
cette crise sanitaire ou le thème de la
frontière de la nation de la
souveraineté est au coeur a en outre
mesure parce que comme viennent de le
dire frédéric dabi et c'était différé à
l'époque de jean marie le pen
cassandre peut avoir raison mais
cassandre fait peur et a sécurisé je
regardais l'autre jour les professions
de foi des candidats front national aux
élections législatives de 1978 c'est la
première fois qu'on voit le mot invasion
migratoire
alors vous vous projetez en 2020 vous
posez la question aux français il ya
beaucoup de gens qui vont vous dire oui
effectivement il ya un problème avec
l'immigration
alors jean marie le pen vous dira et je
l'avais bien dit et 1978 ça suffit pas
de le dire et ça suffit pas de le dire
en avance il faut d'une part avoir un
programme pour y répondre
et puis il faut avoir le casting
gouvernemental que les français s'en
aller dans le moindre détail du
secrétariat d'état peuvent avoir quand
même dans la tête et aujourd'hui voilà
posons la question français marine le
pen et présidente de la république
le ministre de l'intérieur qui va mettre
fin revient dans un dijon c'est qui le
ministre de la justice qui va traiter
les affaires c'est qui le ministre de la
santé qui auraient mieux fait qu'olivier
ferrand c'est qui est là autant dans les
parties mainstream
on a quelques noms qui énerve quand même
autant ça s'appelle le déficit de
présidentialité je pense que c'est un
problème qui n'est pas résolu et surtout
le feu est effectivement sur les
questions régaliennes et l'insécurité
elle a eu des mots extrêmement forts
tout à l'heure à dijon elle parle de
chaos sécuritaire dans le pays est l'ex
team que le pays est au bord de la
guerre civile à l'écouté et elle tape
sur sur les responsables politiques en
place n'étant pas capables de maintenir
dit elle la civilisation dans dans le
pays en ne faisant pas respecter les
lois
ce genre d'actualité là et la manière
dont les réponses et du carburant pour
le rassemblement national ou pas on est
là on voit que la mort de jean raspail
et quand même marqué et compris marine
le pen parce que c'est exactement enfin
cette cette décadence civilisationnel
c'est exactement ce que disait jean
raspail dans le camp des saints c'est
pas pour rien que par une le pen a réagi
à son décès samedi soir dernier
normalement tout ce que l'on voit la
crise sanitaire les événements de dijon
les casseurs que l'on a vu tout à
l'heure à quelques centaines de mètres
d'ici tout cela doit effectivement abîmé
le pouvoir et profiter à marine le pen
je ne dis pas que ça n'abîme pas le
pouvoir je pense que seule la bim
mais ça ne profite pas nécessairement
marine le pen parce qu'encore une fois
les solutions pratiques
c'est quoi ce soir l'elysée annonce que
parmi les ressortissants étrangers qui
sont impliqués dans les violences de
dijon et bien voilà il y en a certains
qui pourrait la fois être expulsé alors
certains diront trop peu trop tard mais
il n'empêche que maintenant marine le
pen se retrouve du coup en nécessité de
faire mieux et plus fort mais qui croit
véritablement à sa capacité si elle
était aux manettes d'ailleurs ce ne
serait pas elle qui se résume à naître
ce sera encore une fois un ministre de
l'intérieur il ya qui croient
véritablement à sa capacité d'un coup de
baguette magique à redresser une
situation qui est le fruit de
renoncements successifs d'échecs
successifs mais on sent qu'elle veut
préempter un cette séquence très
sécuritaire il ya des manifestations on
l'a vu celle des soignants a dégénéré en
fin de cortège
ça peut mieux marcher si j'ose dire que
sur les questions sanitaires a
clairement oui puisque c'est vrai que
quand on interroge les français qui ont
déjà vautier qui seraient prêts à voter
pour le rassemblement national
le diptyque immigration insécurité gens
peuvent même rajouté islam identité
constitue un levier de vote majeur c'est
ce type qui que ce quadriptyque qui peut
également favoriser la porosité entre
l'électorat droite électorat du
rassemblement national qui sont acquis
sur ces sujets autour de la question
économique à une des vraies frontières
des points de vue très différents
autant sur ces sujets là on est sur des
électeurs à qui peuvent être en fusion
c'était très fortement le cas ça l'est
moins
que maintenant il ya dans le jeu
politique en marche et surtout et même
accro et edouard philippe qui arrive à
capter notamment edouard philippe la
droite des mails macron ses électeurs de
droite qui veulent de l'ordre qui
veulent de la sécurité c'est ce qu'avait
esquisse qui avait expliqué la remontée
assez nette de popularité du couple
exécutif après la crise des filets
jaunes là où marine le pen a quand même
un coup à jouer
c'est que il ya une sorte de
d'enchaînements de feuilletons nisation
d'événements et des choses extrêmement
spectaculaires dans les intentions de
vote
elle augmente si si la présidentielle
avait lieu demain alors elle arrive à
des à des scores il fait il est dans une
quête au 18 octobre dernier mais très
clairement elle en situation d'arriver
au second tour car elle à son socle et
c'est clair que elle ferait mais avec
bien sûr beaucoup de prudence et 2017
est un bon warning sur c'est à dire on
avait personnels mac ronde de trois ans
avant l frais nettement mieux que son
score 2-2 second tour de mai 2017 mais
c'est ça aussi la une des conséquences
au delà de marine le pen de la fin de la
bipolarisation gauche droite et de ce
monde politique éclaté éparpillés et
maël macron est un président certes
structurellement impopulaire mais
aujourd'hui on peine à voir un
réceptacle aux mécontentements à
réceptacle partisans quand on quand on
interroge dans le baromètre
il faut fiducial pour paris match le
parti qui incarne le mieux l'opposition
c'est clairement le rassemblement
national et ce depuis les gilet jaune il
ya eu un passage de témoin avec la
france est soumise
appelez-nous son score à la
présidentielle au premier tour 4 %
au-dessus à votre avis au premier tour
je vais pas me prononcer comme ça ce ne
serait pas très très sérieux mais ce
deuxième tour c'est être con 3% 3 août
oui elle pourrait très bien avoir la
barre des 40 états unis ou ailleurs elle
était à 7 bar là avant le débat
catastrophique d'entre deux tours en
tout cas il ya de plus en plus
d'intellectuels d'observateurs qui
disent qu'elle peut accéder au pouvoir
on joue à se faire peur ou c'est une
option je reste sceptique je préférais
examinée et débattue au soir du second
tour que l'avoir jetée aux oubliettes
est arrivé au second tour mais tout va
dépendre aussi comment marine le pen va
négocier un tournant très intéressant
qu'elle essaye de prendre en ce moment
qui est
justement cet appel est l'héritage
gaulliste cette manière de dépasser
justement l'impopularité qui est le
pendant de sa popularité dans son socle
par l'invocation des mains du général de
gaulle
[Musique]
mais pourquoi le général de gaulle parce
que s'il reste dans la mémoire des
français c'est comme quelqu'un qui était
au dessus des partis est quelqu'un qui
dans des circonstances difficiles celle
de 1940 mais aussi celle de 1958 mais
aussi celle de 1961 au moment du coup
généraux mais aussi le 30 mai 1968 a
réussi j'allais dire à tirer la france
vers le haut et à rassembler au delà des
clivages partisans
elle essaye de elle essaye de rassembler
les parvient à ce qu'elle arrive à
élargir son électorat
je dirais oui non il ya quand même des
catégories qui était pas du tout acquise
au rassemblement national et là ce sont
pas des sondages c'est par exemple les
élections européennes dernier vote
national où par exemple
marine le pen est arrivé en tête chez
les 25 34 ans est arrivé en tête chez
les 50-64 ans la catégorie qui va des
catégories qui en plus veut s'offrir
très fortement les 25-34 ans des
générations de l'insertion les 50-54 ans
ceux qui sont tendanciellement mis
dehors des entreprises des conséquences
de la crise économique
il reste des digues dont je parlais tout
à l'heure les personnes les plus âgées
les cadres supérieurs et les professions
libérales les diplômés mais invoquer le
général de gaulle se placer au dessus
des partis
c'est une stratégie que même jean marie
le pen avait essayé d'échafauder au soir
du premier tour je suis socialement de
gauche the nine est nationalement de
droite et au dessus des partis
bon ça n'a jamais embrayé là aussi elle
a un atout par rapport à 2017 c'est que
le président de la république même mâcon
s'il se représente aura un bilan que
beaucoup verront comme un boulet ou
comme un passif et le les difficultés
qu'elle a eue lors du débat d'entre deux
tours pour être nettement moins forte en
tout cas c'est quelqu'un qui reste
incontournable dans le champ politique
on redonne la parole vous conclurez dans
un instant mais j'aimerais bien qu'on
essaye de regarder ce qui se passe outre
atlantique 1 on l'a dit cette faiblesse
des populistes dans la crise sanitaire
l exit même quand ils sont au
gouvernement donald trump au aux états
unis bonsoir françois durpaire
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
évidemment historien et spécialiste des
états unis à qui profitent les
manifestations anti raciste massive en
ce moment dans toutes les villes des
états unis
myriam vous savez qu'il est plus facile
d'être candidat populiste de l'ordre que
d'être président populiste de l'ordre
parce que lorsque vous êtes président
vous êtes comptable de ce qui se passe
dans la rue qu'est ce qui se passe dans
la rue et américaines ou tord bible vous
avez d'un côté des black light matin la
vie des douars compte et puis de l'autre
les blue lines matin l'uniforme bleu des
policiers américains et donald trump
donc il doit prendre des décisions
il en a pris une aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
c'était un décret un décret dit lundi un
très très favorable à la police qui
rappelle le besoin de moyens pour être
un président de la loi et de l'or mais
quand même en créant un fichier national
tous les policiers qui auront quelque
chose à se reprocher ne pourront pas ne
pourront pas se recycler dans un autre
département de police avait il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de police aux états
unis de l'autre côté vous avez dubaï de
dubaï demi il se présente plus comme un
leader rassurant face à cette insécurité
ressentie par beaucoup d'américains et
puis vous savez on l'appelle un peu
celui le seul américain qui a bénéficié
de la crise de la crise sanitaire est
aujourd'hui de la crise sociale et
sécuritaire puisque il est à + 8 par
rapport à a2 dans le train c'est même
fox news le met à + 9 par rapport à
donner le point commun dans votre débat
avec la france c'est que peut-être que
l'élection ne se jouera pas du tout sur
les questions d'ordre de sécurité mais
sur la fameuse question économique et
aujourd'hui c'était les bons chiffres de
l'économie américaine incluse 17 27%
ventes au détail c'est un chiffre très
de fanon qui fera plaisir au président
américain qui lui donne peut-être des
chances de rattraper son retard que vous
avez le choix entre la force virile face
à l'insécurité du côté de d'attraper la
force apaisé du côté de joe biden merci
beaucoup france
le mot de la fin jean yves camus si ça
se joue sur l'économie c'est pas bon
pour marine le pen
si sur l'économie c'est
incontestablement pas bon pour marine le
pen puisque c'est là que la porosité de
l'électorat avec la droite dite
classique est la plus faible
très clairement les solutions étatiste
du rassemblement national ne plaisent
pas ou libéraux classiques et très
clairement la sortie de l'union
européenne et l'abandon de l'euro reste
éminemment monsieur jeunes y compris les
une partie des électeurs du
rassemblement national qui n'ont pas
connu autre chose que la monnaie commune
merci beaucoup merci à tous les deux
d'être venus sur le plateau de lcp on se
quitte pas sans notre nouvel épisode du
jour d'après collection d'entretien sur
les conséquences du coa navires us la
chine ce soir avec l'ancien ambassadeur
de france à pékin jean maurice ripert
revient sur ce pays d'où est parti le
qu'ovide 19 et qui s'interrogent
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui sur un possible
regain de la contagion regarder bonjour
jean maurice ripert bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous on va parler de la
chine ce pays d'où est partie et le co
vide 19 ce pays que vous connaissez bien
puisque vous étiez ambassadeur de france
à pékin jusqu'à ce jour il jamais bien
le sheed je la connais un peu quelque
chose me dit que vous la connaissez
quand même et elle renforcée ou
affaiblis avec cette crise sanitaire
c'est la grande question alors on va
partir de la situation dans le pays
est ce que la vie a changé pour les
chinois depuis cette crise du
coronavirus on s'attendait plutôt à un
rebond rapide de l'économie
ça n'est pas le cas oui alors vous avez
raison le premier facteur de changement
immédiatement identifiable
c'est la très grave crise économique
comme une chaîne elle n'a pas commencé
que l'épidémie du coronavirus un déjà
2018 puis en 2019 le rythme de la
croissance avait ralenti les
institutions internationales qu'angers
est estimé la croissance entre 4 et 5%
ce qui pour la chine je sais que pour
nous ce serait un miracle mais pour
lâcher ne ça n'est pas assez évidemment
et c'est notamment pour la création
d'emplois et la montée en gamme de
l'économie chinoise
donc le ralentissement économique était
déjà était déjà là et en particulier à
l'épuisement du modèle de développement
chinois a du mal à s'adapter avec la
crise sanitaire à nouveau cap a été
franchi et la chine a reconnu qu'elle
serait qu'elle était en récession
puisque elle annonça chiffres de
croissance de -6% donc la chine comme
tous les pays du monde est atteinte à
par la crue du corona virus certains ont
pensé que la chine ne repartirai plus
vite ce qui était une erreur parce que
c'était le modèle que nous avions en
tête c'était le modèle la chine une
usine du monde mais la demande s'étant
effondrés partout dans le monde
le fonctionnement économique chinois on
est évidemment perturbé la deuxième
chose qui à mon avis a changé et va
changer les contacts que j'ai eus avec
tes amis chinois me le font penser c'est
que le système qui est un système
autoritaire
est en train de ces exagérations et même
de se caricaturer lui-même
on a vu au début de la pandémie
premier réflexe du régime communiste
chinois c'est de nier la réalité et pour
la nier aux yeux du monde
on arrête on enferme et on empêche les
lanceurs d'alert de lancer leur alerte
pour vous jean maurice ripert n'y a
aucun doute la chine le régime de pékin
a menti sur l'ampleur de l'épidémie au
départ le régime de la chine
à l'origine à nier l'ampleur du
phénomène peut être at il eu du mal à
l'évaluer lui-même il faut comprendre
comment fonctionne le système chinois
l'état partie chinois la chine est un
pays puissant la deuxième économie du
monde
ça ne veut pas dire que l'état
fonctionne de la même façon que chez
nous l'état à mon avis en chine est
profondément dysfonctionnelle
la chine est un pays gigantesque qui
fonctionne à travers des responsables de
districts de quartier de district de
mairie de région doublé par des
représentants du parti communiste tous
ces niveaux pour téléphoner à pékin ou à
la capitale régionale puis à pékin en
disant c'est une catastrophe
j'ai des milliers de gens qui viennent
d'être victime du coronavirus il faut du
courage dans un système extrêmement
autoritaire où on est punis en
permanence et où j'ai gouverner par la
peur il faut quand même dire les choses
clairement
eh bien ça ne se produit pas on y ont
réagi comme on peut donc au début
probablement sous-évaluation de la
réalité puis probablement dans un
deuxième temps mensonge par omission
on sait que la chine n'a pas transmis l
oms toutes les données en sa possession
aussi rapidement qu'elles auraient dû
tout le monde sait que l'épidémie a
commencé vers la mi-novembre c'est
seulement en janvier que l' alerte
générale a été lancé il y a eu
certainement dissimulation sur l'ampleur
d'où la rapidité de la propagation donc
c'est vrai les autorités chinoises sont
de mon point de vue je parle à titre
personnel partiellement responsable de
la rapidité du développement de la
pandémie
vous faites confiance à cette enquête
qui a été ouverte
sur l' oms l'organisation mondiale de la
santé dont on sait que voilà la chine
est très est très investi très très
présente dans cette organisation est ce
que vous voyez qu'on aura la vérité
pourquoi pas un jour voir pékin rendre
des comptes
je ne sais pas si on aura la vérité
parce que je ne sais pas s'il ya une
vérité mais je crois qu'il faut choisir
on ne peut pas être contre tout si on
trouve qu'un simple de grandes
puissances pas seulement la chine se
comporte de manière hégémonique de temps
en temps alors il faut faire confiance
au système multilatéral les états
unanime de la chine a été obligé de
suivre le mouvement ont décidé de mener
une enquête indépendante sur l'ensemble
des dysfonctionnements
parce qu'il y en a peut-être d'autres
que c'est difficulté ces dissimulations
chez l'oiseau originel il faut faire
confiance à cette institution
cette institution ce sont des états
alors c'est vrai que l'influencé
chinoise est importante la chine a fait
élire par les moyens traditionnels
chinois
le représentant actuelle ça veut pas
dire que c'est un mauvais médecin
ça veut dire qu'il est sous pression il
n'y a aucun doute là dessus mais l'om
est ce ce sont des milliers d'experts
français américains belges australiens
néo zélandaise du d'afrique à tous ces
gens auraient pu probablement aussi se
comporter différemment donc il est
important que ce soit toute
l'institution qu'ils soient mises en
cause sinon une éventuelle mise en cause
de la chine ne serait pas crédible
je voudrais vous ramener à un petit peu
plus en arrière on est le 10 mars
amour and shipping triomphalement
annonce à son peuple d'une certaine
manière que c'en est fini de l'épidémie
en chine qu'elle a été maîtrisé et puis
c'est le début de ce qu'on a appelé la
diplomatie du masque les chinois n'ont
plus que
ton bienveillant et des alliés partout
en tout cas dans les pays qui souffrent
de l'épidémie distribuer en vendant des
tonnes et des tonnes de masques c'est
quoi cette diplomatie là est ce que
c'était nouveau et pourquoi dans quel
intérêt
ah qu'est ce que cherchait et qu'un en
faisant sa diplomatie du sourire ce
n'est pas nouveau dans l'empiré du
milieu la bataille des mots est
important sur la scène internationale le
problème des masques
il a été parfaitement compris je crois
que les chinois sont rendu compte très
vite quand même que tout le monde
s'était rendu compte qu'il y avait eu un
problème au début de l'épidémie et la
chine avait besoin passez moi
l'expression de se racheter
il se trouve que la chine par l'ampleur
de la catastrophe probable qu'à
provoquer il convient de 19 en chine pas
seulement à mourad mais sur l'ensemble
du territoire à 2 fait assécher les
marchés du masque parce qu'elle en avait
besoin et elle s'est donc retrouvé
quasiment l'unique producteur au monde
de masques dans des quantités
suffisantes pour aider les états qui
n'en avaient pas assez elle s'en
procurer alors elle a pu en fournir très
rapidement cette diplomatie elle a
énormément agacé d'occident et
particulièrement donald trump qui n'a
pas hésité à parler d'un virus chinois
et qui a immédiatement retiré son
soutien de l' oms
est-ce qu'on va vers une forme de guerre
froide entre les états unis d'abord sur
le chinois les virus comme vous le savez
le strass le h5n1 maintenant coville 19
son nez c'est vrai sur des marchés liés
à la consommation de certains animaux ce
qu'on peut quand même reproché à la
chine c'est pas de sa faute
bien entendu sauf que la lutte contre la
consommation de ces produits la baisse
sur le marché
tout le monde sait il suffit de se
promener dans les petites villes
chinoises pour savoir que partout on
continue à manger du singe du chien du
serpent du congo là tout ce que vous
voudrez bien donc il n'y a pas eu cette
capacité de l'état chinois à contrôler
ça c'est quand même un problème
cela dit c'est pas si loin parce qu'il
est né en chine malheureusement je ne
crois pas qu'on soit on se dirige dans
une deuxième guerre froide parce que
c'était pas ça la guerre froide la
guerre froide c'était deux blocs unis
chacun derrière un pays qui les menait
la rue celle de l'urss la russie les
états unis et qui s'affrontaient pour
des gains géostratégique
ça n'est pas le cas on est
malheureusement aujourd'hui dans une
situation où certains des clients dire
on a voulu un monde multipolaire on a un
monde multipolaire mais on appris de
multilatéralisme
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas de moyens de
régulation de ce monde bipolaire et
l'europe est bien le rsa la chine change
de ton également oui mais leur or entre
dans une ère de tension très forte entre
la chine et les états unis d'autres et
l'europe
d'une certaine manière ne veut plus
jouer les naïfs vis-à-vis de pékin
oui je tuerai qu'il est en moi j'ai
aussi travaillé pour l'union européenne
soutient la seule l'union européenne je
crois que on a trop longtemps
sous-estimé la puissance que représente
l europe
l'europe est une puissance non militaire
mais c'est une puissance et parmi les
quatre grands blocs de quatre grands
états les etats-unis la chine la russie
et l'europe
moi je crois que l'europe a des moyens
parfaitement se défendre justement parce
que nous ne sommes pas hégémonique nous
n'avons rien nous ne cherchons pas des
gains
contrairement à d'autres et surtout nous
sommes attachés au fonctionnement du
système multilatéral
parce que nous en avons besoin plus que
les autres nous sommes entendus de la
chine
le grand marché intérieur européen la
chine en a besoin
alors il faut entre guillemets négocier
l'accès des chinois pour dérocher noah
on n'est pas américain on ne pratique
pas la menace ont pratiquement les
mesures de rétorsion mais ça veut pas
dire en effet que nous sommes naïfs la
diplomatie du paillasson ça ne marche
pas avec des grandes puissances
merci beaucoup jean maurice ripert
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci à vous
[Musique]
et insiste achève cette émission on se
retrouve demain pour un nouveau ça vous
regarde même lieu même heure
ici la très belle soirée sur lcp soirée
documentaire avec l'intégration
[Musique]